Hey Marvel fans.
We are here with
David Dastmalchian.
We are on the carpet right
now for Marvel Spider-man
No Way Home right now.
How excited are you
for this carpet?
I'm so excited
being back on a Marvel
red carpet at a
premiere for a Marvel
film and it's Spider-man.
And all the exciting
things that are
about to happen in this movie
that I've just been teased
by with the trailer, I'm like--
I know we're all about
to get our minds blown.
But this is like historic
Marvel filmmaking right now
because there's all these
elements to this new movie
that we've never
gotten to see before.
Absolutely.
Is there anyone you're super
excited to see on the carpet
today?
I was really hoping I'd get
to run into Alfred Molina.
I don't know if he's around.
I mean, Tom and Zendaya and
all the incredible stars
of this movie.
Like I'm big fans of everybody
that is a part of the movie,
so I'm just geeking
out over everybody.
That's awesome.
Now Spider-man is beloved
by the entire world.
What makes him so relatable
to you and everybody else?
It's like when
you were a teenager
and all of a sudden
everything starts changing
and the world seems like
it doesn't make any sense,
Peter Parker is the embodiment
of that for all of us.
He's like-- His body starts
changing all these things start
happening that he has no
control over and all of a sudden
he has this choice to make.
Like, what am I going to
do with all this change?
Am I going to do something
to make the world better?
Or am I going to turn all that
anger and confusion and fear
into something dark?
And he continues to inspire
us because over the decades
Peter Parker and
Spider-man continue
to rise to the occasion
and be the hero
that we need them to be.
I absolutely love that.
Hope, positivity.
Enjoy the red carpet.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you.
Thanks, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]